mehr als 1000 corona infizierte der
kreis gütersloh macht die fleischfabrik
tönnies für zwei wochen dicht und
beklagt die schlechte zusammenarbeit
massenveranstaltungen trotz corona
gefahr us-präsident komplett tausende
anhänger in einer halle und bezeichnet
demonstranten als plündere und gesindel
und entscheidung im abstiegskampf
vertagt werder bremen verliert in mainz
und kämpft am letzten spieltag mit
düsseldorf um den relegationsplatz in
der fußball bundesliga
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zu dieser samstagsausgabe der
heute -nachrichten norbert lehmann ist
auch dabei für den sport ein symbol von
mir ungewöhnlich deutlich wurde heute
der leiter des krisenstabs in gütersloh
das vertrauen in die firma tönnies sei
auf 0
die fleischfabrik hätte die adressen
ihrer mitarbeiter nicht freiwillig
herausgegeben die behörden müssten sie
sich in der nacht vom firmengelände
holen wenn ihr selbst zeigt sich
betroffen verweist aber auf datenschutz
richtlinien die zahl der infizierten in
den schlachtbetrieb ist mittlerweile auf
1029 gestiegen
orange das system turniers stoppen
proteste vor dem werk in rheda
wiedenbrück tierschützer und anwohner
demonstrieren gegen die zustände beim
fleisch konzern am nachmittag dann eine
pressekonferenz des kreises gütersloh
der leiter des krisenstabs ist sauer auf
turniers da das unternehmen keine
vollständigen personal listen an die
behörden übermittelt habe wir kommen nur
dann die menschen dran wenn wir wissen
wo sie wohnen und deswegen sind wir
gestern späten abend mit dem
arbeitsschutz bei der firma tönnies
gewesen nachdem wir ordnungsverfügungen
nachdem es sozusagen mit guten zureden
nicht geklappt hat ordnungsverfügung
erlassen haben das uns tatsächlich
komplett alle personal listen an der
stelle vorgelegt werden über 1300
adressen im kreis gütersloh müssen die
behörden nun abfahren um die quarantäne
zu kontrollieren und die bewohner weiter
aufzuklären über 7000 menschen müssen zu
hause bleiben
das verhältnis zwischen kreis und
konzern ist mehr als angespannt
also ich will erst mal sagen das
vertrauen dass wir in die familie
wir setzen ist er auf null das muss ich
so klar sagen
eine botschaft die bei turniers wohl an
kam noch eine pressekonferenz nur wenig
später der firmenchef clemens tönnies
der auch unter quarantäne steht geht
überraschend persönlich vor die kameras
er entschuldigt sich und verweist bei
der zusammenarbeit mit dem kreis auf
probleme mit dem datenschutz
wir haben datenschutzrechtliche probleme
eigentlich dürfen wir diese adressen
nicht haben das ist wird der datenschutz
und auch das werk die werkvertrags das
werkvertragsrecht gibt uns eigentlich
nicht das recht diese daten bzw die
wohnadressen zu haben die behörden
versuchen einen lock down für den kreis
gütersloh zu verhindern
ob es auch gelingt ist noch unklar
lothar becker ist für uns vor ort vor
den toren von tönnies was ist dran an
den vorwürfen die firma habe nicht
kooperiert das problem sind die
werkverträge dieses system von menschen
die selbstständig sind als sub
unternehmer für andere unternehmer
arbeiten und diese unternehmer
vermitteln dann die arbeitskräfte
hierher das klingt nicht nur kompliziert
das ist es auch und das macht es wohl
teilweise tatsächlich unmöglich zu
wissen wer denn tatsächlich hier
arbeitet wo der hier wohnt und so ist es
wohl eine mischung aus einem na ja sagen
wir sehr komplexen system und schlicht
um unvermögen die daten aller
mitarbeiter so heraus zu geben dass man
möglichst schnell für sicherheit sorgen
kann
alle mitarbeiter von turniers also etwa
7000 menschen sind in quarantäne viele
von ihnen sprechen kaum deutsch und gibt
es den wie werden die versorgt das soll
nun also geregelt werden es ist ja die
bundeswehr hier im einsatz es ist das
deutsche rote kreuz im einsatz madita
hilfsdienst und das technische hilfswerk
und auch die firma tönnies betont dass
sie drei bis vier mal die woche frische
lebensmittel und dinge des täglichen
bedarfs an die mitarbeiter liefern
möchte ob und wie gut dass in den
kommenden tagen läuft das bleibt
abzuwarten es ist auch noch vollkommen
unklar ob die quarantäne denn überhaupt
funktioniert so soll es bauzäune geben
die also um wohngebäude und areale
aufgestellt wurden in denen die turniers
mitarbeiter leben die nun unter
quarantäne stehen und es dann wird man
in einigen tagen wissen ob das virus aus
der belegschaft den weg hinaus in die
gesellschaft in den landkreis gütersloh
geschafft hat dankeschön für diese
informationen lothar becker die zahl der
neu infizierten in deutschland bleibt
zwar auf etwas höherem niveau ist aber
erstmals seit drei tagen wieder leicht
gesunken
nimmt man den durchschnitt der
vergangenen woche haben sich 440
menschen täglich neu angesteckt gestern
lag der wert noch bei 450 deutschland
ist bislang glimpflich durch die
pandemie gekommen es gab mehr
intensivbetten als nötig jeder co at 19
patient der intensivbehandlung brauchte
hat sie auch bekommen und damit die
chance zu überleben
aus der uniklinik aachen berichtet torge
bode heute zum tag der intensivmedizin
der weg zurück ins leben ist für
wolfgang schäfer anstrengend noch immer
raubt ihm jeder schritt den atem
der 54 jährige hat einen schweren cupid
19 verlauf durchlitten acht wochen
künstliches koma jetzt in der reha hat
er wieder ein festes ziel vor augen
wieder der alte zu werden 55 jahre
gebraucht um so zu werden wie ich war
und jetzt möchte ich da auch wieder hin
weiter zu machen
gut 14.000 corona patienten wurden
bisher in diesem jahr auf
intensivstation in deutschland behandelt
auch für das medizinische personal der
uniklinik aachen war wird 19
herausfordernd der kampf um jedes leben
die angst vor einer ansteckung das ist
belastend
[Musik]
stressige situation hatten oder an
schwierigen patienten fördern wird das
auch meistens noch mal nachgesprochen
intensiv medizin ist vor allem teamwork
ärztinnen und ärzte das pflegepersonal
und andere experten dazu jede menge
maschinen von denen leben abhängen kann
daher verbinden viele patienten die
intensivstation mit technik und tod zu
unrecht jedes jahr in deutschland und
viele tausend frauen männer kümmern sich
eben in ganz deutschland auch ganz viel
intensivstationen tag und nacht um diese
patienten und weit über 90 prozent
überleben und kommen auch zurück ins
leben
auch wolfgang schäfer hat das geschafft
durch ein engagiertes team moderne
technik und den eigenen willen
schon vor der korona krise waren
fehlender wohnraum und explodierende
mieten ein problem jetzt könnte sich die
lage weiter verschärfen
bundesweit sind deshalb mieter
initiativen auf die straße gegangen wie
hier in berlin
sie fordern mehr mieterschutz im herbst
könnte eine welle am zwangsräumungen
drohen wenn menschen ihre mieten wegen
der korona krise nicht zahlen können
fürchten die initiative wegen der
pandemie gilt seit april ein
kündigungsschutz
der läuft aber ende des monats aus in
vielen teilen der welt breitet sich
corona nach wie vor rasant aus vor allem
in lateinamerika und dort besonders in
brasilien
inzwischen haben sich mehr als eine
million brasilianer mit dem virus
infiziert die zahl geht steil nach oben
allein gestern wurden fast 55.000 neue
ansteckungen registriert
und das obwohl vergleichsweise wenig
getestet wird präsident bravo hat corona
von anfang an kleingeredet mehr corona
infizierte als in brasilien gibt es nur
in den usa
doch der präsident will wieder massen um
sich scharen mitten in der pandemie für
seinen ersten wahlkampfauftritt heute
will jump 20.000 menschen versammeln und
zwar ausgerechnet in taucha oklahoma
dort von 1921 eines der schlimmsten
massaker an schwarzen statt angesichts
der anhaltenden proteste gegen rassismus
empfinden viele diese auswahl als
provokation
elmar theveßen seit tagen singen sie
warten auf ihr idol
viele haben vor der halle übernachtet
inntals oklahoma fast 20.000 menschen
wollen trotz corona gefahr donald trump
zu jubeln weil sie ihn für den besten us
präsidenten der geschichte halten jeden
tag opfert er sich für uns für jeden von
uns egal wer wir sind ob schwarz weiß
asiatisch gelb es ist ihm egal
[Musik]
eben jener präsident wirft nun per tweet
alle demonstranten in einen topf mit
anarchisten plünderern abschaum wie er
schreibt er droht mit hartem vorgehen
dabei feierten am freitag wie hier in
washington doch hunderttausende im
ganzen land friedlich den john teams sie
erinnern an den einsatzbefehl vom 19
juni 1865 mit dem general granger auch
im letzten winkel der republik galveston
texas verkündete dass alle sklaven frei
sein
das versprechen von gleichheit hat sich
für viele schwarze in amerika bis heute
nicht erfüllt rassismus dürfen sie den
präsidenten vor der seine kundgebung
ursprünglich auf genau diesen tag gelegt
hat wir sind nur hier und hoffen etwas
zu verändern
weitgehend friedlich bis auf den umsturz
von symbolen für den rassismus wie die
statue eines südstaaten generals in
washington zur politik der cdu
nachwuchspolitiker philipp am tor und
seine umstrittenen nebentätigkeiten
jetzt wird wieder über ein lobbyregister
für den bundestag diskutiert es soll
kontakte von abgeordneten zu unternehmen
erfassen
der parlamentarische geschäftsführer der
unions-fraktion große brömer will es
noch in dieser legislaturperiode auf den
weg bringen am tor hatte gestern abend
auf die kandidatur für den cdu
landesvorsitz in seiner heimat
mecklenburg vorpommern verzichtet nach
serbien seit jahren will das land
mitglied in der eu werden morgen wählen
die serben ein neues parlament
staatspräsident cic konnte in der korona
pandemie mit seinem krisen-management
punkten
trotz wirtschaftlich angespannter lage
und gestiegene arbeitslosigkeit seine
fortschrittspartei gilt als favorit
seine gegner werfen ihm allerdings vor
die opposition zu unterdrücken
sie rufen dazu auf die wahl zu
boykottieren aus belgrad wolf christian
ullrich trat ein djilas kennt man gut in
belgrad er war bürgermeister der
serbischen hauptstadt doch jetzt kämpft
er dafür dass keiner wählen geht seit
jahren hatte kein oppositionsführer die
gelegenheit etwas auf einem nationalen
tv-sender zu sagen die leute wissen also
gar nicht was wir wollen und deshalb ist
seine wahl auch sinnlos serbiens
präsident alexander mutet dagegen ist
seit jahren auf allen kanälen so
vermittelt es sogar sein wahlwerbespot
ich finde alles läuft demokratisch und
die medien waren nie offener als jetzt
sagt der präsident
ein tv duell mit der opposition wie in
jeder anderen demokratie gibt es
trotzdem nicht mit ihm
vor dem parlament demonstrierten
oppositionspolitiker gegen eine
politische kultur von gezielter
diffamierung und mobbing durch die
regierungspartei
wenn ich in eine baracke verlässt die
hälfte der gäste den raum aus angst mit
mir fotografiert zu werden
die opfer vom mut regime nennen diese
studentischen aktivisten ihre aktion mit
der sie auf korruption und gewalt
missbrauch in serbien hinweisen wollen
wir brauchen ein system in dem mein tipp
verhaftet wird und diejenigen die
korrupt sind die gerichte bedrohen die
stehen und lügen auch 43 prozent der
jugendlichen in serbien glauben nicht
mehr an die demokratie als bestes system
nur jeder zehnte meint er habe
politischen einfluss ich werde nicht
wählen gehen wir kennen ja schon das
ergebnis das ist doch dauernd im
fernsehen wenn morgen weniger als die
hälfte der wähler zur urne ginge wäre
die legitimation von vujic macht
deutlich angekratzt in belarus also
weißrussland wird anfang august gewählt
eine echte wahl haben die menschen aber
wohl nicht präsident lukaschenko geht
mit harter hand gegen die opposition vor
allein gestern gab es bei protesten mehr
als 100 festnahmen melden aktivisten
die demonstranten hatten gefordert dass
oppositionspolitiker zur wahl zugelassen
werden
der aussichtsreichste kontrahent
lukaschenko und weitere
regierungskritiker sitzen bereits in
haft
jetzt zu einer fast philosophischen
frage kann man vergangenheit kaufen etwa
besondere momente der musikgeschichte
zum beispiel das unplugged-konzert von
nirvana mit curt cobain wurde die
auftritte von prinz auf dem höhepunkt
seiner karriere ein bisschen davon ist
jetzt versteigert worden
zwei gitarren der beiden verstorbenen
künstler wie viel vergangenheit daran
hängen muss lassen die gebote ahnen
andreas stamm
die zerbrechliche seite eines rockstars
curt cobain und nirvana 1993 während des
mtv unplugged auftritt das daraus
entstandene live-album für manche das
beste seiner art
[Musik]
die martin de 18 die cobain während
dieses meilensteins der musikgeschichte
spielt kommt in diesen stunden in einer
online auktion unter den hammer
eine rarität viele instrumente hat
cobain der sich mit 27 das leben nahm
nicht hinterlassen
wir haben schon einzelne gitarren teile
versteigert mit lose raushängen seiten
cobain hatte sie auf der bühne
zertrümmert das war sein ding seine show
aber zu dieser gitarre hatte er eine
besondere beziehung nach seinem tod 1994
ist sie ein familienerbstück geworden
günstig ist das erbe einflussreicher
rockstars nicht in teil 1 der auktion
wechselte gestern eine gitarren
sonderanfertigung für print den besitzer
für eine halbe million dollar
die hoffnung von martin nolan cobains
gitarre soll mehr als 3,7 millionen
bringen rekord für eine gitarren
versteigerung cobains strickjacke ging
für 334 1000 dollar weg ich hoffe sehr
dass der damalige biete auch die gitarre
kauft beide wiedervereinigt
ein kommerziell erfolgreiches happy end
für cobain der an seinem erfolg zu
grunde ging wäre es wohl ein albtraum
vielleicht hätte er auch diese gitarre
besser zertrümmern sollen spannenden
abstiegskampf
ja denn noch steht der zweite absteiger
neben paderborn nicht fest aber fest
steht mainz 05 ist es nicht die
rheinhessen gewannen das kellerduell
zuhause gegen werder bremen mit 3 2 1 im
stadion wäre es den mainzern natürlich
lieber gewesen aber so ging es auch die
klassenerhalt feiern
nach einer schwachen saison es werden
auf jeden fall uns mehr gewünscht
vorjahr im vorfeld aber in dortmund in
bremen haben wir die klasse gezeigt
deswegen nie mehr zweite liga post so
ähnlich wie hier in mainz freuten sich
auch fans in augsburg und köln über den
sicheren verbleib in der bundesliga in
bremen muss weiter gezittert werden nur
ein sieg am samstag gegen köln kann den
abstieg noch verhindern
denn düsseldorf bei union berlin nicht
gewinnt nächsten samstag dann werden die
fans wieder auf die folter gespannt und
hier die ergebnisse des 33 spieltags
mainz bremen also 3 2 1 bayern schlägt
freiburg ebenfalls mit 3 zu 1 leipzig
und der liegt dortmund nur zu zwei
klarer sieg für hoffenheim gegen union
berlin 14 0
düsseldorf und augsburg trennen sich
unentschieden eins zu eins herter
besiegt leverkusen mit 2 0
schalke unterliegt wolfsburg mit 1 zu 4
köln frankfurt 1 zu 1 und paderborn
verliert gegen gladbach eins zu drei
die tabelle die bayern schon seit
dienstag wieder meister dortmund seit
heute wieder vizemeister bleibt dritter
gladbach jetzt wieder vor leverkusen im
zweikampf um einen
champions-league-platz wolfsburg
sechster punktgleich mit hoffenheim im
zweikampf um einen europa league platz
die zweite tabellenhälfte beginnt mit
herta und am ende der zwei kampf um den
relegationsplatz düsseldorf 16 2 punkte
vor bremen als siebzehnter ja und
bereits abgestiegen paderborn alle
spiele alle tore dieses vorletzten
spieltag bei uns im aktuellen
sportstudio um 23 uhr gesprächspartner
von katrin müller hohenstein ist
unter anderem bayern vorstand oliver
kahn zum finalturnier der
basketball-bundesliga da hat nach
ludwigsburg und ulm als drittes team
oldenburg das halbfinale erreicht die
mannschaft gewann auch das
viertelfinal-rückspiel gegen bamberg der
oldenburger jubel gar nicht mal so
ausgelassen zu deutlich die
überlegenheit gegen bamberg im
viertelfinale
die niedersachsen hatten schon das erste
spiel mit fünf punkten unterschied
gewonnen anfang der zweiten hälfte
ziehen sie dann auch entscheidend im
rückspiel davon
oldenburg dominanter als man das vorher
erwarten konnte gewinnt 89 zu 75 bester
werfer in münchen alle spiele finden in
derselben halle unter strengen
hygienevorschriften stadt ihren hammer
mit 21 punkten
ja und der vierte halbfinalist ist
wieder berlin oder götting die spielen
gleich noch bei morgen wissen der
abi-jahrgang 2020 muss corona bedingt
auf vieles verzichten die meisten feiern
sind abgesagt aber es geht auch anders
autostadt aula hupkonzert statt applaus
ist es heute für die abiturienten eines
oranienburger gymnasiums die abi
zeugnisse gab es im drive-in trotz
corona regeln konnten alle dabei sein
und das wetter spielte da auch keine
rolle morgen gibt es regen und sonne was
wo in welcher reihenfolge erzählt gleich
ist in terni das heute journal um
zwanzig vor elf mit marietta slomka
machen sie sich noch einen schönen abend
danke für ihr interesse und bis morgen
wenn sie mögen
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter heute ist sommer
beginnen und in der kommenden woche
erreichte uns deutlich wärmere luft und
zwar kommt sie von spanien über
frankreich zu uns und so knacken wir
mehrfach die 30 grad marke der kommenden
nacht aber erst einmal regen im osten
und viele wolken im süden auch da sind
schauer im westen klart es auf und die
temperaturen sinken auf 15 grad an der
ostsee und 7 grad im hessischen bergland
morgen am vormittag halten sich im osten
die wolken und es regnet noch und im
süden bilden sich neue schauer sonst
scheint häufig die sonne zum nachmittag
dann im osten weniger regen der letzte
allmählich nach im süden aber ist aber
noch mit schauern zu tun
vom emsland herren kommen dann zum abend
hin neue schauer auf sonst dazwischen
viel sonnenschein bei temperaturen von
26 grad im rhein-main-gebiet und am
niederrhein 20 grad an der ostsee die
kommenden tage am montag im süden
schauer und davon einige ansonsten aber
meist lockeres locker bewölkten himmel
20 bis 26 grad und am dienstag wird es
heiss bis 30 mittwoch bis 31 grad und
viel sonnenschein damit ein schöner
abend